Promethea in fact why don't we just skip
ahead a little bit rather than start at
the beginning of Promethea we can jump
forward a bunch of levels and I want to
show you some pretty exciting action
here in the lore Promethea is the
headquarters of the Atlas corporation
and you'll notice as we proceed that
Atlas is actually under siege by malian
and their private army you see in
Borderlands in this universe when a
corporation attempts a hostile takeover
they do it with full military grade
force now before we start I want you to
take a look at the gun we're using here
this is an Atlas pistol now the cool
thing about an atlas pistol is it has an
alt fire mode that fires out a tracking
Dart and when you fire the tracking dart
it marks a target and then every bullet
that you fire subsequently will hit that
target it's like the Fifth Element gun
finally so let me introduce our demo
ist's we've got Chris Chris is playing
as Zane and Zane is gonna be our co-op
buddy this time and Paul is playing
Azamara which is what's on screen for us
to watch you'll notice Amara and Zane
are both at level 10 and we've actually
set them up with microphones so that we
can listen in on their chatter as they
play Paul Chris you guys ready I'm good
hey all right so let's let's watch this
is the world's first Borderlands 3 co-op
livestream taking away Paul and Chris
after you all right I'm going in its
punch enemies over here I'm gonna head
on the right side and try and split them
up I see a couple behind cover I'm gonna
just pop the tracker
[Applause]
switching over knee
melting on steel clicking the fire your
ground slam yeah keep down one on the
left still wore Packers in doesn't get
more I'm just gonna rain grenades on the
crowd
dear miss my dog hit him with a grenade
gone down so you've just heard from
Lorelai she's an all-new NPC we skip
past her introductions since we skipped
ahead and we skipped also a lot of her
storyline but trust that you'll be able
to meet and spend a lot of time with
Lorelai and other NPCs as you explore
Promethea and the other worlds of
borderlands 3
you guys ready to finish the fight let's
go do it I'm going to run right all
right I'm gonna throw down the shield
cool give a swing into the shield taking
out shield for you yeah
thinking it out future necrosis for that
striking possible
night
all right I got a big crowd on the left
here gonna switch to the shotgun flat
super go for the pack
guy
she's got two more over here nice last
one
leave them nice I feel chest back here
let's see what you get all right when I
can't use when I can got a torque got a
bunch of light off pistols that level
twelve a little okay but you guys can
save it Oh delayed fire mode great move
on all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
taking us